it's been that way uh forever for all of
you in history literally right and this
big split with like CRT happened a big
fissure moment was occupied by Wall
Street there's that famous cartoon where
it's all the people protesting saying
we're the 99 and then the rich guys in
the room and he says introduce them to
Identity politics I so and we might get
into this later you know but I told
Lydia it was I was gonna bring it up I
said and I I have a jump off point so
I'm going with it we at human events we
found a tumblr post by 12 Clara who was
a universe who's a user there who
basically admitted
that Glee the TV show was the plague
ship for wokeness into the American
mainstream what the TV show plague ship
was the plague ship this user now 12
Clara was one of like the leaders of the
Glee online fandom on Tumblr this post
she wrote which is basically like an
Epitaph to all of that is admitted just
admitting all of this where do you guys
think the word problematic came from
where do you guys think that the idea of
um the representation anger you know do
we have do we have a character who fits
this demographic that demographic do you
have a character who's this who's that
right that all comes right from from
Glee and from the original Glee fandom
and then the wars because people get mad
about it be arise from this idea of
people becoming not just sympathetic for
the characters but actually empathetic
by actually viewing the television
character as a mirror image of
themselves where that where it's not
only identity politics from the sense of
racial in general her but identity
politics from the idea of I identify
with a TV character because and don't be
wrong I love the work that Chris rofo
and James Lindsey have done tracking
this stuff academically but people have
not tracked the pop culture history of
wokeness to explain why it came about
and when if you look at the history of
Glee and Occupy Wall Street that sort of
you know middle 2010s milieu and people
don't realize social media that show
hitting social media pre-netflix right
all of these things hitting at the same
time just launched all of this stuff
into this track but I I think social
media is the biggest driver of all of it
um I I think Glee played a role in pop
culture but I think it's part uh when
did Glee come out do you know what year
it starts 2009 yeah and then it got big
by in 2011 is when it got big the exact
beginning but I still think it's social
media it's but that's what I'm saying
though it's the combination of social
media with these TV shows that are
introducing people it's not time it's
not Academia I think I know and I agree
with you on that Peter pagosia and I
have debated this stuff
may have originated there in some sense
but these guys on that nobody on Tumblr
is you know going and reading these
academics it's that when you at
universities there's a bunch of
different ideologies correct there's
critical race theory used to be there
there used to be but uh this is the one
ideology you know critical race theory
that comes out and expands and it's
because intersectionality was a social
media was a prime vector for stuffing
keywords and articles so you can say you
know trans women of color being
experiencing police brutality is the
epitome of black lives matter and you've
had every single keyword you get more
views and thus critical race theories
starts becoming more prominent
there you go yeah no I don't see this I
don't see this as necessarily being uh
uh in in conjunction with that or or in
contrast to that what I'm saying is this
is you've got to read this post right
it's it's just amazing What She lays out
where she's on Twitter or something this
oh we have the whole thing everywhere
right um Lydia I think I said where the
post-millennial did it yeah the post
millennial did so our version is like
super long and gets into like a ton of
different things they went in and did
basically a summary we just post her
tumblr post you know when they posted it
in 2017. I like how you doing the first
Millennial posted that no personal
posted today oh okay word and then what
it's called it is I think you just work
if you look up glee it'll probably come
up I like how you mentioned the
psychosis that can come from identifying
with the TV character which isn't a real
person exactly and this is where which
Game of Thrones character are you which
Glee character are you exactly these
people like so the popularity of those
shows plus intersectionality hitting
identity politics and social media at
the same time you put this was a TV show
by the way that was getting 30 million
people in ratings at one point right
this is a massive here's massive
cultural here's a story from post
millennial entertainment consultant
admits Glee sparked the woke movement
within the U.S oh did I mention that by
the way the Tumblr user 12 Clara it did
an interview with Salon where she kind
of like quasi-outed herself in in terms
of real name and said oh by the way my
real name is Aaron what do you do now I
work as a Hollywood entertainment
consultant wow nice of course of course
they all come from Tumblr so were they
consulted at the time
no no no so when they were on Tumblr and
involved in in like the toxic Glee
fandom no
um right there the glean fandom is not
history it's blood I still see it all
over this website the vague post the
deactivated URLs where do you think the
word problematic became popular where do
you think the representational anger
Glee was the hungry gaping void that
consumed us all it's it said watch us
and watch us and find yourself there's
something from everyone and there's
characters lesbian characters gay
characters bisexual etc etc et cetera it
goes on and on and on and said this is
your only outlet for body positivity we
are all oppressed by something but we
are different and we are Outcast and we
are you everyone's oppressed so long as
you agree with them exactly if you
challenge it and say an individual can
be strong and they say no because I
think it's really simple well and this
is
telling an individual they're strong
breaks their collectivism
telling an individual they're weak and
oppressed means you have to be a part of
the collective otherwise you'll be
victimized well and this is amazing
because it's like the show portrays all
the protagonists of the show and we do
mention of course the Glee curse and we
get into that as well a little bit
but it portrays all of the main
characters as victimized and oppressed
and all of this when you've got the uh
captain of the football team the captain
of the cheerleading squad you know these
people they're they're all gorgeous
they're great singers they're putting on
like somehow they're able to do Broadway
level Productions at like some random
high school in Ohio and they seem to be
quite popular across stage and screen in
in Universe right in the show and yet
they're told that they are victimized
and oppressed and then they wear that as
the branch of Honor
this I'm telling you that audience that
came up watching this show and then the
other shows that spun off of it this was
one of the biggest plague ships of
wokeness into the Main Street ship the
plague ship yeah like I'm not saying
this is like and people were you know
we're trying to Flame the comments you
know when I posted on Twitter today they
said
this isn't the very first place that we
saw a political correctness this isn't
wasn't like guys I'm not saying that I'm
saying this was one of the biggest
vectors but because the later seasons of
it sucked and because of the Glee curse
which and you know horrific things the
fact that three of the main characters
are now or the three of the main actors
are now deceased whoa what what yeah no
seriously so Corey Monteith dies first
he he was the original main character
right and one of the show uh heods 2013.
oh wow during the show's course so he he
OD'd and this was the captain of the
football team character uh who od's then
you know what happened to Mark salling
right no I don't watch Khali I don't
know these people are I mean there's a
huge story though
um so I think it was while the show was
wrapping up he gets busted for child
porn whoa and this was sort of like the
bad guy so he was sort of like the the
foil for the main football player he was
like you know the tight end or something
on the team but he was like the bad boy
who cheated on the cheerleader with you
know with him and everything
and he gets busted for child porn uh
gets arrested later hangs himself wow
yeah and then
um the other cheerleader not the captain
but Santana drown and this this is
legitimate tragedy this is just uh just
a real tragedy just last year she
drowned in in a lake outside of Los
Angeles while trying to save her
four-year-old son their boat had
capsized or something yeah and she's she
gets her son back in they find the sun
later on alone and have no idea where
the mother is they find her body you
know later on you know and that's brutal
man but you know just this crazy they
call it like the Glee curse do you think
that it was um so what I'm saying my my
contention is that and as horrific as
all those things are my contention is
the fact that Glee isn't in the
discourse as much anymore is because
people talk about it in terms of this
curse but they also totally Overlook the
fact that it was the plague ship that
introduced a lot of wokeness to a huge
broad swath particularly of Millennials
who are watching this thing because
remember we know they weren't working in
2009 right you know nobody's got jobs
everybody's you know maybe going into
more debt while they're working on their
masters and they're they're starting to
sign up to Twitter they're starting to
sign up to Tumblr and what are they
talking about they're talking about Glee
and they would have been 10 and 12 years
old now they're 23. do you think that it
was intentionally produced that way to
do that or just more like this is how we
these people happen to feel like victims
and they wrote a show about so we we
researched this and then I didn't write
the piece but I did edit it and one
thing that we do track is that when the
show was originally written it was
actually kind of like a parody right
sort of a parody of like High School
Musical and it was satirical it was
actually kind of tongue-in-cheek and it
was meant to be self-aware and it was
the fandom that turned it into that so
when the fandom became so incredibly
tribal about I demand that my character
that I identify with go through these
you know aspects or the whole idea of if
you know anything about fan culture uh
shipping right do you guys know shipping
oh man so okay what is shipping so
shipping is basically where you like
create this my mindset where these
people that you see in the show are in a
relationship right it's like a fan right
or so you want the characters to be in a
relationship but then in some aspects of
some fandoms it gets so bad that you
actually start making up these like
conspiracies that the actors themselves
are also secretly in a relationship they
did this by the way with the Star Wars
movies the Disney Star Wars movies they
called themselves raidlos right and dead
serious and the reylos all believed that
Adam Driver and um what's the girl's
name Daisy Daisy Ripley
um had were in a secret relationship
they started harassing Adam driver's
actual wife in real life because again
the parasocial relationship went beyond
right so you've got an empathetic media
Mass psychosis you know formation going
on where they need they have an
insatiable urge for their false reality
or what we might call it a metaverse
reality to come in and actually take the
form in the real world to the point
where the fact that Adam Driver is
actually married to someone separate and
that he's a real person who's you know
I'm sure he's in love with his wife
that's why he married her
um that she needs to be removed from the
story because that does not satisfy the
beliefs of the reylos too what are
humans
yeah I know right and it's and it's
amazing and it's wild and unfortunately
it's all true and the fact that people
overlook this influent the toxic
influence and you could look at other
shows like so I the reason that I'm kind
of halfway into this stuff is because I
originally started my Twitter account
and blog in 2012 to make fun of the Game
of Thrones TV show and so I sort of came
up online through that and then
eventually got into making fun of
politics and here I am
um and so but I remember that the Game
of Thrones online fandom was just as bad
but no it wasn't as big as Glee was at
the time but it was it was ridiculous
and I remember like I got kicked out of
the the DC Game of Thrones book club
because you know I I remember saying I
thought it was funny that people were
pirating all the episodes and so HBO
wasn't getting any of the money and
these people lost their minds they
completely lost their mind I got banned
from the Game of Thrones Reddit I got
banned from all these different things
because I didn't have these types of
like false empathetic media
relationships whereas other people were
were literally I they could not separate
themselves from that false reality and I
think by the way the most ubiquitous one
of these of all
um the reason I don't mention it in
terms of wokeness is because it's not
particularly woke though is Harry Potter
right and and there is a reason that
every aging childless millennial
will always use Harry Potter as their
reference their frame of reference for
literally everything there's this creepy
post on Reddit where this uh teenage
girl was like my parents named me after
a Harry Potter character my brother
after a Star Wars character they're
obsessed with it we hate it we hate all
of it we get made fun of
Millennials man thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this Channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time